أجل
[موسيقى]
في البداية حتى قبل الكلمة
بدءا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحاخامية
الكثير
شكرًا
لا تكن من مصطفى ولا تكن من خديجة
نشأت أصلاً في بورصة
أخ من أرتفين
الحمد لله كل حياتي شبابي
لعائلتي التي استمتعت بوجودي
لأمي وأبي وإخوتي كاميلاما
كانت فارغة بصلواتهم
مع الكثير من الدعم
حياة حلوة لتحمل هذه المحنة
مع النضال
لقد وصلنا إلى هذا الحد ، المستوى التعليمي هو الأول
درسنا في بورصة في البداية
بعد هذه العملية ، قدمنا ​​أيضًا موجزًا
هل هو مدرس لتدريب الذاكرة نعم
جئنا إلى اسطنبول مرة أخرى ، التمثيل و
كتابة السيناريو ذات الصلة
تدريبنا على الإخراج
العقل يحاول أن يكمله في اسطنبول
آخر 14 15 عامًا في صناعة السينما
لنفترض أننا نحاول الوجود
ما دام اسم هذا المسجد إنساني
ما هي ديناميات المجتمع من الناحية الفنية؟
تحاول أن تكون شخصًا مفيدًا
نحن نعمل
[موسيقى]
في الواقع ، الإجابة على هذا السؤال واضحة جدًا.
ربنا يأمرنا بالقرآن فورا.
وجه
الرجل ذو الرأس الأسود الذي يصفه لا يزال متأخراً
هذا الكروم المربع هو قلم للعالم
عوالمك لك
أنا أقرأ أول 5 آيات من خلقك
ليس لدي معينين من ربك.
خلقت روز من جلطته بقلم
لم يكتب كما قرأت
تطوير نفسها ، إنشاء Laz we
المسلمون هم أول أمر الله
الشاغل الأول هو أننا نولد أولاً.
لقد حان الوقت بالفعل للحياة مع أطفالك
تبدأ في التأسيس
تبدأ العالم منازلنا
التي وجدتها في نفسك
في العالم من أنا ما أنا لماذا
أنا موجود ، لماذا أتيت إلى هذا العالم؟
لي لماذا لماذا علامات الاستفهام هذه
إنه مثل بحث إبراهيم عن الله.
اليوم يقول ربي إنني أتساءل عما إذا كانت نجمة
النجوم تقول لا ، نحن رب
لا يمكن أن يكون اليوم الذي تعطيه الشمس في طفولتي
يدفعونها يتكسر ويقول نفس قراءتها نفس الشيء
ألا نستطيع أن نكون عندما يقول الوقت ربي
كلهم مبدعون. هذا علم.
التفكير هو التفكير
أثناء البحث عن دول جديدة في الوطن
لذا فقد مضى
شكرا للاله
أنا ممتن جدا لربي
عائلتي هي دعم كبير لي في هذا الأمر س
خليل ماذا أفعل بالمعنى الإنساني؟
مستقبلك حساس مرة واحدة
أنت تدخل ، ليس لدينا خيار آخر في هذا العالم
حياتك شبابك بالطبع
بأفضل طريقة مررت بها
ستعيش هذا يسمى الجدة
مر العمر يا أخي ، تبدو مختلفة مهمة
عندما تكون صغيرًا ، تجول في العمل أو شيء من هذا القبيل
لذا تعال متأخرًا ، حان دور الشخص البالغ من العمر 20 عامًا
خذ 50 كيلو من الدقيق واصعد إلى الطابق V.
الآن يمكننا أن نصطف نحن البشر
الوقت الشباب أن الطاقة البشرية
برضا الله أولا وقبل كل شيء في النشاطات
داخل تلك الدائرة ليتم رؤيتها
لذلك أنا لا أحاول وضع الأنشطة
يجعلني مباركا
أعتقد الأيتام مع ذلك على وجهك
كونك بجانب الصيادين يتعلق بأفريقيا
وفي القدس وسوريا والشرق
تقع تركستان في كل جغرافيا العالم
هناك اضطرابات البوسنة لديها البلقان
أي عقل الناس
لأن هذا هو اسم الأمل
عندما دخلت في هذه المواقف على هذا النظام الغذائي
شهرتي لها هذا التأثير في أفضل صورها.
كيف نعتقد أنه مفيد للناس
الوقت ربي يتحرك الروحي
يجلب النعمة velhamdulillah
انا اقدر لكم
والله مثلا نحن في فمك.
آيا صوفيا للمسجد الثمين بالنسبة لنا أيضًا
الأكثر خاصة
نحن الثروات المعمارية والروحية
نحن سوف
على سبيل المثال ، لا تذهب بالطريقة التي فعلها أسلافك.
خلفنا مباشرة مسجد السلطان أحمد.
هناك مطابخ عثمانية للحساء حولنا.
والناس من جميع أنحاء العالم
لذلك هو قادم لرؤيتهم
ما الجحيم 700s rc500 مسلسل واحد
منذ سنوات في النسب
كونه مؤمنًا ومهندسًا معماريًا
إنه فن ورجل وعالم
يمكن أن تكون المزيد من الأماكن التي نذهب إليها
الوقت أفكر أكثر حتى قبل 1303
هناك الكثير من الأمثلة على ذلك
كلما زاد عدد العلماء لدينا
التفكك الثقافي
لدينا ثروات لماذا الآن
تأكد من عدم وجود التكنولوجيا الحالية
لو كانت الفترة في زمن الفاتح لكانت قليلاً
أنا أعطي مثالا على عثمان غازي بتوقيت أرطغرل
سيكون الأمر مختلفًا كثيرًا لو كان غازي في الوقت المناسب.
بنيت على قمة حضارة
يجب القيام به مع المستحيلات
الأشياء التي تم العمل عليها ولكن هناك فرصة الآن
سلفي لا ، لماذا ليس هكذا
دعني أخبرك ، لقد وضعنا أمريكا في البرنامج.
نحن ندخل إنجلترا ، ها هو تايلان
المناطق الأفريقية يوم الجمعة ، ها هي قطر
الحمد لله في العديد من البلدان ذهبنا إليها
لا في غالبية البرامج
نحاول أن نكون مركزين
لذلك دعونا نرى تركيا الآن
على خطى مستشاري اللغة في بعض المناطق
هاني هو أكثر إنسان موثوق به على الإطلاق.
يساعد مع الشركات الصادقة
إنه واضح في إفريقيا ، تمامًا مثل التنزيل
جغرافيتهم مع هؤلاء الناس مثل الأيتام.
نحن نحاول العمل
بقدر و و
إنها أيضًا محادثة
لا يجب أن تعمل غرفة لهم والوصول إلى هناك
الناس بالطبع لا يأتون فقط الأعداء
ربما الخبر من قبل المديرية أعلاه
تتحدث عندما تتلقى
الحمد لله لقد أنعم الله علي عدة مرات
مخيط
وعلى سبيل المثال لدينا ابنة اسمها ماريا
نأمل قريبا في أمريكا
قال إنه سيندم على ذلك
والدتها تعني الخطأ
إذا كان لا يتذكر ويرى المستقبل
ها هي محجبة شوهدت منذ فترة طويلة
لم أستطع التعرف على سرعتنا أثناء ارتداء التنورة
ربما هناك فتاة نحبك كثيرا
بسبب المسلسل وأيضا في الإسلام
سأكون سعيدًا جدًا لاستكشاف أي منها
قلت ابنتنا
نظرت ، فسنهم خجول جدا
قال إنه جلس ، شكرًا لك يا أخي
مرحبا لاني قلت لكم يا رفاق
أنا أبحث عن عملك على الإنترنت
أنا قادم لمشاركتك ، أنا سعيد جدًا
انا والتكوين والتأسيس عثمان
مسلسلات تركية ومسلسلات أخرى
اثنان من رؤساءنا جدا
تركيا كدولة في هذه المرحلة
كأمة في جغرافية الأمة
لتكون مع كل المظلومين
يقدم الأمل للناس
يفتحه الناس لفترة طويلة أيضًا
يارب اريد ان اتي اليك
أردت أن أستمع قال ما شاء الله كثيرا
أنا سعيد أن أليف قادم إلى يافوز الآن
صديقاتي يبتعدن عن المطبخ
لماذا ينتظرون في كمين ورؤوسهم مغطاة؟
أردت أن أكون مثلهم وارتديته
يقول أن الحجاب كان شعورًا لطيفًا
قلت انها تبدو جميلة ايضا
قلت جميل ما شاء الله أرجو قراءة القرآن
إذا أخبرت كريم هل ستقرأه؟
نحن نحقق في اللغة الإنجليزية وسنكون سعداء للغاية
أنا أسمينا القرآن
نحن نص ولكن لا نفرض
لأنه قال إنه كان يحقق
لا إذا كان هناك أي شيء تريد أن تسأله عنه
يبلغ ابني حاليًا 19 عامًا و 16 عامًا
الكثير من إجابات علامة الاستفهام
وجدناها في القرآن ، مثل هذه العشرة
قبل 15 يومًا ، كان شقيقنا الحالي يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا
أصبح مسلما في أمريكا
لحم مفروم أتينا 1 كل منا لا يقول شيئًا
لا يوجد طعم ، يقول أنا لست ملكي
أنا أبحث ، لكن الإلحاد هو أداة الربوبية
البحث نبدأ كل شيء ولكن
المسلسل يقول بأزماته
مرحباً ، ترى مساجدنا
يقول: يرى صلواتنا ويقول أن الله
خطبهم للنبي والآيات
قلت في اللحظة التي أستمع فيها إلى هذا
أنا سعيد وأتينا وتحدثنا
اريد ان اكون بالفعل ما شاء الله لك
بدأت في التفكير ، ميفلا
ربي من مسافة 11 ألف كيلومتر 12
أسبوع خمسة عشر كيلومترًا منك هناك
يستغرق الأمر ولكنه يعني لكنه هناك
طفل حديث الولادة من الأم
مثل كل مدرسة نظيفة 121
أضعهم على قدميك
أنا أقبل الدواخل ، أشفق ، الله منك
شكرا لك كم كلفك هذا الانسان
ربي أحضر هذه الشهادة إلى أحد أقدامنا.
عمقت الفقراء شعور خاص جدا جدا
أشياء خاصة يا رجل
نحن سوف
يعيش ، يولد ، يموت ، بعد موته ، برحمة
لا يوجد شيء أهم يجب تذكره هنا
من وجهة النظر هذه ، يمكننا المغادرة
بارك الله في دولتنا
بارك الله في رئيسنا SRT و
قالت شركات بناء أخرى إننا هنا
منظمة عثمان محمد بك كمال وغيره
جميع التواريخ لشركات البناء لدينا
بارك الله في كل المترجمين.
كانوا على علم أو ليسوا في الواقع فقط
نحن لا نهمل سلسلة في ثقافتنا
نحن نصنع ونصنع في حياتنا الإيمانية
نحن في مناطق جغرافية عديدة
حتى لو لم يفاجأ الناس بالإيمان
الأسلمة ودراسة الإسلام
وأنتم قادمون إلى تركيا يخت أجنبي عليها
إنهم ليسوا مسلمين ، إنهم يعاملوننا بشكل جيد للغاية
هناك صور جئنا تسحبنا
يقول مع الشخص الذي كان يرتدي ملابس 60/4
لقد جاء وفعل شيئًا جيدًا
يتغيرون
في الحقيقة مرة أخرى
كنت تبحث في البلقان الثلوج للأسف
الديون في مقدونيا وغيرها
المناطق الجغرافية
انت تعلم انه عاش في العراق
إلى سوريا هو مندي والجغرافيا الأخرى
دول أفريقيا وأمريكا الجنوبية و
أمل العالم كله متحف
يحتاج الأمل معا
ما الذي يجب حفظه
تلك الأمة التي صنعها العثمانيون
توحيد الناس الذي أخذ الإنسانية
صنع أجدادنا 607 سائقين
عندما تشاهدهم
هذا يجب أن يكون
فعال ، هاه ما لا أفهمه
لقد فعلها أصدقاؤنا وهي وظيفة لطيفة للغاية
خطأ الجميع هو بالضرورة خطأ ما فعلته
كان ينقصها ولكن الآثار جيدة جدا عاكف
لا نزال نمر عليك باكستان
عبد الحميد يجلس في بعض القرى
الناس جاهزون في نسل حمار ما الذي تفعله
عربي في الشرق الأوسط منذ 400-500 عام
في بلدان أخرى ، في البلقان
حدث ، ولكن ليس الرئيسي
ليس تركي
وكذلك فعل الاخوة بالذهب و
قد تكون هناك أخطاء سياسية أيضًا.
أخطائهم السياسية
وجد أنه مثير للجدل ولكن الخدمة
شكرا لك سالم الذي حاول
كما تعلم ، لم أذهب إلى الكعبة إلى المطهرة.
العمل على ورقة الخدمة لدينا وهذا أيضا جدا
أشياء لطيفة أي شعب في تلك الأوقات
آه لقد سمعوا جميع أنحاء العالم الآن
حاجة سلمية الحلق أملهم
لا توجد مقاطع فيديو
هناك خجول لذلك ذهبت إلى تركيا
الوقت نراكم في تركيا القمر والنجمة
أيتام ، أنت تعانق آزوف
يقدمون لك التركية ، يحبونك
لقد ذهب إلى تايلاند ، ولهذا السبب
الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم في ذلك الشهر
ظل صفاء العلم المرصع بالنجوم
اريد السعادة
لا يريدك صندوق التصرف في السيارة
خطبة الوداع أكبر دليل على ذلك.
جعلونا نشعر بالبرد تجاه بعضنا البعض 10
سطور واثنان منا لبعضنا البعض
لقد ذموا
حسنًا ، لقد أصبح الأشرار هم جيدين
الصبي هم أبطال ولكننا
أكلنا ، نحن الآن مستيقظين
هي بلدي لا تختلف عني ونحن
انت شخص yg8 ان شاء الله اتمنى
الثقافة والفن ومعا مرة أخرى يا أخي
مشاعري بالفعل الآن
[تصفيق]
لم نتمكن من تشغيل هذا وإعداد شهر رمضان
نشارك شهر رمضان أي بطوننا
حتى المساء
[موسيقى]
اتركها فارغة
ترك الصلاة في النهار
من خلال عدم قراءة آذاننا والصلاة
لا نصلي صلاتنا في المساء مع التراويح
إنه هناك عندما لا نذهب إلى هادي رمضان
القليل مفقود والمشاركة زكاة
الخيرية هي أيضا أقرب جيراننا
قدمها مع الناس من حولنا و
التسامح مع رمضان نتحدث بحرية
نتحدث السياح على الجانب الآخر
الآيس كريم يقول الجانب الجميل من ديننا
هذا التسامح أنه يصوم بإيمانه
إنه لا يصمد ، لكن لا أحد يتدخل مع أحد
لا أحد يضطهد أحدا
على سبيل المثال ، يحدث التسامح أحيانًا
أعطي الرجل المخلوق بالطبع
صوم غير المسلم بجانبك
قد لا يصمد العالم ، أنت طعامي
إذا لم يأكل ، يتفاعل
عليك أن تتحلى بالصبر بالطبع مع هذا الشخص.
فكر في الأمر ، وهم يصومون أيضًا في رمضان.
شيء منفصل لكنك قد لا تعرفه
عليك أن تكون متسامحاً
فليكن مع القرآن يا سيدي
دعهم يستكشفون حياة المحارب
الممتلكات المتعلقة بأحاديث سيدنا
الوصول إلى هناك ومساعدة طاقاتهم لا
حسنات الصدقات والزكاة
دعهم يحاولون أن يكونوا مشغولين
كما ترون ، السلطان أبي مليء بالصلصة.
مثل مساجدنا في جميع الأوقات ، كل يوم.
ليأتي مع طلب واحد على الأقل
فليعملوا رحمة المساجد وبركاتها
الأمر مختلف الآن
نحن في حضور آيا صوفيا على كل طاولة
المخابرات السماوية فاتح سلطان محمد خان
تكريمه بحمد الرسول
أصبح القائد العظيم لملصق اسطنبول TL
سيكون هناك بوابة للقائد الذي غزاها
قائد عظيم الجندي الذي احتلها
إنه جندينا ، تم الثناء عليه
نحن في الحقل المقدس
وآمل أن تكونا شخصيًا من هنا.
شاهدونا ايها الاخوة والاخوات ربي دائما
أدعو الله أن يمنح هذا القلب صحة جيدة
أتمنى أن تتاح لك فرصة القراءة
لنعمل اخواننا العرب طبعا
ونحن كملوك التلاوة الحسنة له
لسنا في القسم لإعطاء الرفوف الآن
حتى لو بقي
تنام بالله مناش انها عار الاخت
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الإشتراك
وجه
LA ما ترك الأم القوس
هذه
إلزي
والله العراق
مرحبًا كات كراك مع مصباح يدوي
فى الحال
انت تقود
البعثة
tefor الصدر و Erol مرة واحدة ferunda
Sadakallahu أ أ
[موسيقى]
اشترك